dany l'angle est économiste et membre
des économistes atterrés
bonsoir danyluk merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur rtl france la première
question quel regard vous portez sur cet
accord et 15% de taxation pour les
entreprises multinationales et est-ce
que c'est suffisant alors j'aimerais
quand même rappeler au départ que au
début des années 80 le les taux moyens
de taxation ont été autour de 50 % les
taux moyen d'impôts sur les sociétés
alors on peut estimer que c'est que
c'est beaucoup mais c'est juste pour
rappeler
quarante ans plus tard don vient donc on
est aujourd'hui avec des taux
d'imposition extrêmement faible avec une
concurrence fiscale donc 15 % c'est
finalement c'est pas monstrueux par
rapport à ce qu'avait proposé le job
hayden aux états unis qui est 21 % de
taux minimal et puis par ailleurs le dia
le sera dans les détails maintenant il
faut voir dans l'accord ce qui est prévu
en particulier en matière de
progressivité de l'impôt parce que
j'aimerais quand même rappeler que quand
on regarde les rapports qui concerne
l'imposition en france et en particulier
les publications des syndicats des
impôts et bien l'impôt sur les sociétés
est dégressif avec des petites
entreprises qui payent autour de 30% et
des très grands groupes qui parfois ne
paye que d'un pour cent
donc est-ce que cet accord prévoit
également de se débarrasser de ces
dispositif fiscal qui permet aux grands
groupes d'échapper à l'impôt ça va être
une question intéressante et qu'est ce
qu'on va faire contre tous les montages
fiscaux qui permettent à des entreprises
comme google ou amazon ne quasiment pas
payer d'impôts alors que le petit
commerce du coin lui il t'a posé
beaucoup plus lourdement
mais globalement est-ce que cet accord
il va permettre de lutter par exemple
contre la dame ping fiscale a bien
écouté
je ne sais pas il faudrait il regarde
dans les détails de l'accord qui n'ont
pas encore été publiés sur internet donc
rentrer dans les détails
15 % ça me paraît quand même
relativement peu par rapport à
l'ambition de 21% qui a été lancé par
les états unis
alors nouvelle réforme portée par l'
ocde elle est acceptée à l'unanimité
mais certains pays pourraient être
réfractaires comme l'irlande par exemple
attaché à un taux d'impôt plus
compétitifs 12 20 800 %
oui et d'ailleurs dire non s'est
illustré à plusieurs reprises par le
passé en refusant par exemple les
décisions de la commission européenne
oblige y ont enfin un élan google et
amazon à s'affranchir des décisions de
la commission européenne qui voulait
imposer un taux supérieur donc voient
imposer ou imposé des taxes pour non
respect des règles fiscales à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
c'est traditionnel les yeux bandés
impose lourdement leur ménage il impose
lourdement la consommation et ils font
des cadeaux fiscaux aux grands groupes
dans l'espoir de les attirer mais à ce
jeu là vous comprenez bien c'est très
vite les chaises tournantes et donc on
va aller s'installer dans d'autres pays
et donc qu'il va falloir imposer ça aux
irlandais sous
sous la menace de son dessus alors cet
impôt mondial
il est quand même soutenu par les états
unis ce cas votre avis y a pas un peu de
déception
outre atlantique parce que la france
souhaite absolument que cette taxation
elles soient bien l'imposer aux autres
géants du numérique c'est le cas
contrairement aux états unis écoutez ou
aux états unis en fin moulé me semble
que le gouvernement français sur tous
les aspects et très en retrait par
rapport aux propositions
très ambitieuse que font manamia
l'administrent l'économie aux états unis
et monsieur bill dann ça a été une bonne
surprise générale de revoir retour en
grâce de l'imposition et puis ça
correspond aussi à ce qui était vu alors
il faut reconnaître à monsieur le maire
d'avoir toujours voulu imposer les
géants du numérique ça il faut lui
reconnaître mais on ne peut pas
présenter ce qui a été obtenu comme une
grande victoire de la france parce que
la france a eu un discours extrêmement
changeant sur l'imposition sur les
sociétés et la concurrence fiscale la
g7-finances 1 c'est un aperçu du g20
finances qu'elle va se tenir les 9 et 10
juillet prochain à venise
que faut-il en attendre t plus on est
nombreux plus il est difficile d'obtenir
un accord donc c'est un point de départ
c'est un point de départ qui est
nettement insuffisant
et c'est un point de départ où il faudra
se montrer très vigilant sur les détails
de la manière dont les choses vont être
taxés et donc de la manière dont on va
évitez pouvoir éviter tous les
mécanismes actuels qui permettent
d'échapper à l'impôt et qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement nombreux
extrêmement malsain et on a quand même
dans l'union européenne
plusieurs paradis fiscaux et en
particulier les pays bas le luxembourg
le lichtenstein et cetera et cetera
donc il va falloir être extrêmement
ferme sur ses principes et je ne suis
pas convaincu que les gouvernements
aujourd'hui au pouvoir qui sont quand
même les gouvernements qui sont
favorables aux grandes entreprises
soient fermement déterminés à faire
respecter cet accord et voir aller plus
loin et j'espère précisé d'année langues
ce sont les pays en fait un qui abrite
les sièges de ces multinationales qui
pourront taxes et ça vient ça si on
voudrait que les choses soient
clairement fait il faudrait les ne
respectent pas la règle du jeu puissent
être sanctionnés par les autres pays et
en particulier en europe dans le cadre
de l'union européenne
or c'est toujours difficile parce que
l'europe dans laquelle nous sommes et
une europe qui est à mi chemin entre le
fédéral et d'un talent gouvernementale
et ses prérogatives fiscales relève de
l'intergouvernemental et donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'arriver à
imposer un accord comme ça en europe
aujourd'hui
ceci étant dit les traités permettant
même d'appliquer aux pays qui ne
respectent pas merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste membre des économistes
atterrés